so now we've seen rotation by
multiplying j by j over and over again
and we see that that's that's rotation
now let's do it for the general idea of
any any complex number so if i have a
complex number
we'll call it z
and we'll say it's made of two parts a
real part called a
and an imaginary part called b
so now what i want to do is what happens
if we multiply z by j one time
j
times z
and that equals
j
times
a plus j
b
and let's just multiply it through
equals j times a
plus
j
times j
times b
a and b have now switched places so
we're going to put j a on this side
j a on this side and what do we have
here j times j is minus one
so we have minus b
plus j a
so now we have expressions for z and jz
and i want to go plot these on a complex
plane and see what see what they look
like
and here's the real axis here's the
imaginary axis
and let's first plot
let's plot z let's say z has a large
real value
and that would be a
and let's say that b is is a smaller
value we'll put b
here and that means that z is at a
location in the complex plane right
there
we can plot
the dotted lines
that's z in the complex plane
so now let's put jz on the same plot jz
has a
has a real component of minus b so that
would be right about here
here's minus b
and it has a imaginary component of plus
a
so let's swing a
a goes all the way up to about here
and so that's the location of
j z
and let me draw the hypotenuse of that
this is the vector representing j z
right there
so now we have a bunch of triangles on
the page and what i want to demonstrate
is that this angle right here
is 90 degrees
so one way to do that let's see if we
can do that let's say this angle here is
theta
that's the angle
right there
now this triangle here this triangle
that we've sketched in just imagine in
your head that we're going to rotate
that angle up until
the a leg of that triangle is resting
right here on the imaginary axis so this
triangle rotates up to become
this triangle here
since we moved that triangle we know
that this angle here
that's also theta
it's the same triangle just rotated up
and what does that make this angle here
this angle here
that equals
90 degrees
minus theta
so if i combine this theta angle with
this angle here what do i get
theta plus
90 degrees minus theta
and the
we get 90 degrees
so we just showed that this angle right
here is a 90 degree angle
that demonstrates that any complex
number z if i multiply it by j
that results in a positive rotation of
90 degrees
so let's do this rotation again only
this time instead of using
the the rectangular coordinate system
let's use the exponential representation
so in the exponential notation we say in
general
z equals some radius times e
to the j
theta where this is the angle theta and
r is the length of this hypotenuse here
to get out to z
so what is in this notation what is j z
and that equals
j times r
e to the j
theta
so now i'm going to do a little trick
where i'm going to represent j
in exponential notation so if i color in
dark here this is this is j
the vector j
is right there and it has a magnitude of
one and it points straight up on the
imaginary axis so i can represent j like
this i can say j
is e
to the j
90 degrees
that's equivalent to
this j here
and it's multiplied by r
e to the j theta
and now the last step is we just combine
these two exponents together
and we get
j z
equals r
times
e to the j
theta
plus
90 degrees
so in exponential notation we get
this vector here we go
an additional 90 degree rotation and we
go out the same distance we had
originally r
so now we've shown that we can rotate
any complex number by 90 degrees if we
multiply it by j
we're going to get to apply this kind of
transformation to working out the
current and voltage relationships in
inductors and capacitors and that
that'll happen in a couple of videos
from now